every once in a while i see a news
article that absolutely makes me laugh
out loud and the new york post had one
yesterday bitcoin fans are psychopaths
who don't care about anyone study shows
wait what bitcoin fans or psychopaths
well let's dig into exactly what these
claims are of course this science
science rules is really important to pay
attention to because if this is true
this would be a major warning sign right
well inside of the article what we see
is that they went ahead and they
surveyed about 500 people that's right
these bombastic claims are based on a
500 person survey and they said that
many investors exhibit signs of the dark
titan i don't even know how to pronounce
that word but that is a group of four
unsavory traits made up of narcissism
machiavellianism
psychopathy and sadism what the hell are
these people talking about this is
insane but let's continue just to make
sure we really understand it those 566
people that they talked one in four
reported that they owned crypto and
two-thirds showed an interest in crypto
investing according to the researchers
these people are partly drawn to crypto
because they are prepared to take risks
okay well let's keep going and then in
the article it says that the
machiavellians who are good at deception
and take a calculated approach to
achieving goals like crypto primarily
because they distrust politicians and
government agencies if you want to
accomplish your goal isn't everyone
calculated don't you plan on how to
accomplish the goal question you want to
ask yourself is what do i want
what's my outcome what's my result this
all sounds like absolute nonsense it's
the finance version of witchcraft these
people are just giving surveys to 500
people they're pulling it out they're
trying to label them with all these
different insane ideas and then they say
you're calculated because you want to
accomplish your goals that's what every
human in the world does that's what
every successful person in the world
does these people are dumb continuing
here it says to them perhaps both the
pleasure from seeing another's pain and
the fear of missing out are related to
selfishness if you're a crypto fan
yourself don't fear investing doesn't
suddenly make you evil according to dr
wang we studied only a subset of people
interested in crypto who do have these
traits happen to be a bitcoin or other
crypto holder you may or may not exhibit
them so at the end of the article after
all of these insane things that they
said they said by the way maybe we're
right maybe we're not well i think we
need to do is stop using 500 person
surveys to go ahead and extrapolate out
to describe 150 plus million people this
is the insanity that goes on in the
mainstream media and if you're gonna say
bitcoin holders or psychopaths just wait
till we run our 500 person survey to
describe the media hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time